good morning believe nation today's
message is earn your audience over to
you Neil Peart feeling constantly having
to earn it i think it is good motivation
for it you know I don't take for granted
that people just admire what we do so
whatever we do they'll admire no you
know I feel like in fact this is very
true every audience I feel like we have
to earn them you know that we have to
earn their dedication and their
expenditure of time and energy and money
to be there every single time you know
every show and it's an old show business
thing but I really feel that you're only
as good as your last show and that's the
one thing I do like about touring if you
have a bad one get another chance when I
had my first business I really
underestimated how much work it would be
to get clients to get people to care and
to buy I always felt like listen I'm a
smart person I'm willing to work hard if
I apply myself i figured i would have
success every other thing that I tried
in the past whether some sports to
academics if I tried I would get results
and i figured i would get results in my
business if I was willing to work hard I
wasn't I didn't think like if I slacked
off thing could magically happen it was
willing to put in the work but I thought
would be I thought it would come way
easier than it did little did I know how
how difficult it is to start a business
to build the relationships to get the
customer satisfaction to get people to
care about you and I look at my youtube
channel now and I believe a big part of
the success has been because of you guys
because of the audience most of the
videos that I make now are based off of
feedback and requests for you write the
top ten the ants presses will leave life
a lot of it is just you guys leave
comments and I make a video because of
it and that's insanely joyful for me but
also helps build the trust and their
poor in the community when I started the
channel every comment that was left on
channel I i commented back i left a
response from because i felt like if you
were spending time watch my videos I was
so grateful like I was so grateful at
the art that I was creating other people
cared about enough to leave a comment
and meant so much to me that I felt like
you deserved a reply and it got to the
point where it was just too many
comments in a day and I'm not
complaining I'm super grateful for that
so now I hired a team right so I respond
the comments still every day I'm in the
comments section and my team now is also
in the comments section and I might be
the only youtuber I'm the only one that
I know of who's brought on a team to now
manage some of the comments because the
community is important like you guys the
audience you're important to me and I
really believe that that's part of why
the community believe nation is so
positive i get so many comments on
people saying they love hanging out in
the channel because of not just the
videos but the comment section because
the people are so optimistic and so
supportive and so positive and that
doesn't mean everybody is is an angel
you know we still get the hater who
still get the little man sometimes on
the channel but for the most part people
are really positive and uplifting and I
believe that that's a lot due to me
being involved at the early stages and
still now in the comments and my team
being there too so people know that you
know the person who started this channel
is involved and I think that brought
people closer to me and closer to each
other as well and so I've earned my
audience with every video that I put out
every video has to be good or I'm going
to lose my existing audience and it's
also a first chance for a lot of people
who've never heard of me and this is the
first time you're seeing my video for
some of you watching if this is your
first video that you've ever watched my
channel leave a comment below I want to
hear from you that'd be super excited so
I mean it's insanely difficult to build
a business and you build your audience
base one customer at a time one
relationship at a time one conversation
at a time and when you really care about
your customers when you really care
about your audience when you go that
little extra mile just to show some love
to them then they're going to love you
back and they're going to buy from you
and they're going to tell their friends
about you and they're going to comment
on your videos and i'm going to send
emails about you and that's how you
build your business up yes you need a
great product or service right it has to
write a great value but I massively
underestimated the importance of the
relationship and the service and the
care that goes in to helping customers
achieve the goals that they want so the
question today is how are you earning
your audience I'm really curious to find
out leave in the comments below thank
you guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events best